symmetry it sounds so simple but what is
the definition of symmetry well the word
symmetry comes from the Greek word
Sumitra meany agreement in dimensions
due proportion arrangement however in
mathematics symmetry has a more precise
definition that an object is invariant
to transformation now there are many
types of symmetry such as reflection of
symmetry a line of symmetry going
through an object which divides it into
two pieces which are mirror images of
each other and translational symmetry an
object that has translational symmetry
can be translated without changing its
overall shape and helical symmetry can
be simultaneously translated and rotated
in 3-dimensional space along a line
known as a screw axis
and scale symmetry does not change shape
when it is expanded or contracted eg
fractals
and finally rotational symmetry when an
object has rotational symmetry it can be
rotated about a fixed point without
changing the overall shape today I just
want to focus on rotational symmetry and
what are the order of rotation and angle
of rotation rotational symmetry has to
do with objects that can be rotated
about a pivot and can still coincide
with the original shape at least once in
less than a 300 degrees turn there are
also many rotational symmetrical objects
in daily life even though you may not
notice the Triskelion is also one
example of a 3-foot rotational
symmetrical object and has an order of
rotation meaning the number of matches
you can make in one rotation of three
and it also has the angle of rotation
the degree of the angle away from the
previous match to the next one of 360
over the order of rotation which is 360
over 3 equals 120 degrees there are even
four fold and fivefold shapes of this
form each named after their order of
rotation
to draw one he simply have to draw a
regular shape such as the Pentagon and
then he draw arcs inside the shape and
spirals extending from the vertices
finally you erase the first step